2011 was a banner year for videogames it
saw the release of a new Zelda portal to
Skyrim Arkham City
uncharted 3 dead space 2 Dark Souls Orcs
Must Die and Gears of War 3 just to name
a few
no matter what your prefered genre it
seemed there was something fantastic to
hold your attention and as the year came
to a close
epic games director Cliff Bleszinski
took to the stage at the Spike Video
Game Awards to reveal the studio's new
games a project that was pitched
internally several months ago that came
together lightning fast is something
that seems like a no-brainer to build
and we're still figuring out what to do
with the lightning we have in a bottle
already
for tonight's influences were clear it
would be an evolution of epics horde
mode in Gears of War with the added
building aspects of Minecraft and the
Luke Rhine of Diablo or Borderlands but
of course what wasn't clear was just how
long fortnight would take to congeal it
would fly under the radar for several
years before resurfacing on the cover of
Game Informer magazine in 2014 with the
announcement that it was in fact going
free-to-play people are gonna get the
experience fortnight this year it's
gonna be free yeah and I think you know
that's awesome it's a great way to have
a conversation with with players because
they're not obligated to like it so we
have to do our jobs we have to be an
awesome game creators to say it's worth
your time to play this game
EPIK announced a beta in 2015 but
because of increased scope and ambition
as well as a shift from Unreal Engine
three to four it would take two more
years before we got the chance to see it
again and now we can finally participate
in fortnight's nebulous beta / early
access / pre free-to-play founders
period
I myself have spent close to 20 hours in
the game and I'm sad to say the more I
play the less I want to when I'm most
struck by as how rooted in the past
fortnight seems in fact it doesn't just
feel like a game that was announced in
2011 but a game that released in 2011
it's not just a vanilla combination of
game design tropes but specifically
those that were prevalent at that time
it's combat borrows from call of duty
zombies or Orcs Must Die its crafting
aspects are a superficial minecraft and
most of all for tonight is a game that
focuses far too much on content for
contents sake there are main quests
tutorial quests hero quests daily quests
challenges schematic collections hero
collections survivor collections wall
traps floor traps ceiling traps weapon
upgrades hero upgrades EMT squads
defender squads land expeditions air
expeditions and at least four different
types of loot crate's none of this is to
mention the variety of different
currencies that unlock a variety of
different kinds of loot there are also
certain progression points that accrue
over a set number of real-world hours
essentially gating my progress while I
pursue other mundane time-consuming
endeavors yes I know content is not
inherently a bad thing we all want our
money's worth when we buy a game and we
all want our time to be well spent
playing that game but in fortnight so
little of the overwhelming amount of
loot you get even matters several of the
resources you upgrade your weapons with
are also used to upgrade your traps but
when weapons are far more useful at
least in the earlier hours why spend
your supplies on anything else and why
should you spend hours working for
better traps when you could just pay
real world money for them in a game you
already paid $40 for from what many
people told me the game becomes much
more difficult in the later zones and
rewards creative building much more than
it does earlier on but that doesn't
change the fact that the first dozen
hours are a slog through cluttered
inventory
meaningless quests and mundane combat
all of this is to say that while
fortnight's first few hours lured me
forward like a carrot on a stick
20 hours later I've come to find that
the carrot was fake all along I would be
ok with all of this meaningless content
if the game showed me depth in its
mechanics but it doesn't help that none
of for tonight's gameplay inspirations
have led to any depth on their own
scavenging is boring and not nearly as
frantic as trailers imply combat feels
alright but not nearly as nuanced as
gears of wars horde mode or Orcs Must
Die campaign crafting is largely
ephemeral and most of your creations
lack the permanent value of Minecraft
structures
I think we've moved past the idea of
content being king in the last few years
we've come to realize that just having
things to do does not equate to having
fun companies that used to exemplify
this kind of game design have shown
strong signs of moving on either by
reworking their core systems or
providing new substantial modes that
change their games as we know them the
bottom line is fortnight feels like a
game that values quantity of content
over its quality there's no solid
foundation to build the loot and
progression system on and instead of
reworking its core mechanics over the
last six years it seems as if epic just
stayed in the past and kept piling more
stuff on already unstable ground I also
think all of this is indicative of a
wider problem with epic games who have
in the past several years heralded this
approach as their new monetary
philosophy I paid for what equates to an
early access game that already feels
designed to support a free-to-play model
which will supposedly ask me to pay more
money down the road what's more physical
copies of four and I have popped up on
Amazon for $60 without any indication
that the game is essentially a paid for
beta that will eventually go
free-to-play Paragon the MOBA from epic
games had similar messaging issues it
was unclear when it fully released and
whether we were actually paying for a
game that we could expect to be balanced
worthwhile and rewarding to some extent
you can argue that a plethora of
developers release games with the
intention of updating them after the
fact and I would not disagree but I
think other developers have found ways
to build solid foundations before adding
to them overwatch Rainbow six siege and
titanfall 2 are all prime examples of
superb games before they added anything
more to the formula in the months since
their releases they've continually
proved that they value our money and our
time video games can be an expensive
hobby they can also be time consuming I
just can't get past the feeling that
fortnight's systems were designed around
its content and not the other way around
to be clear I sincerely hope epic finds
a way to make all the stuff in their
game worthwhile but as it stands I can't
recommend for tonight for any of its
individual parts because that's exactly
what it is a collection of foggy systems
that never really gel disguise by a
constant barrage of almost meaningless
loot if you like third-person
tower-defense I'll tell you to play Orcs
Must Die
if you like scavenging for supplies -
then challenge your creative muscles I
would tell you to just stick to
minecraft and if you want a repetitive
RPG that actually rewards you for your
time I would point to Diablo 3 for
tonight goes for all of these things and
fall short offering a shallow
amalgamation of all of these systems
that as it stands now already seems
designed for a free-to-play model
it's the classic case from a few years
ago of a game prioritizing content over
depth many developers have moved past
this school of thinking and I hope epic
does the same
[Music]